[Applause]
[Music]
Tom
here is
[Music]
thank you thank you very much thank you
very much
[Applause]
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
we did not have time for that that's it
good night everybody
there's no time for that I know the
pressures on especially because we got a
guy in the front row who escaped from
prison I know look at this guy
it's a swanky prisons a prison
nonetheless no Andy he's here to support
the cocoa cause Oh same I see an orange
suit I think jail you know Liz Lemon is
great to be back I am happy to announce
right now that the three-month coning
shutdown is officially over
[Applause]
president Trump this is how it's done
right absolutely I love this angle we
didn't have this angle on the old show
check that out getting that fun well
anyway I just tap we're back with a with
a 30 minute show I don't want you to
worry about that it may only be 30
minutes I assure you it's gonna feel
like two hours all right that's the
effect clap along with that the whole
row a whole row was like it's true he
does where I am it already feels like
Wednesday yeah I've got kind of a new
look this is how I dress in real life I
call my look hip biology teacher ya know
I'm the cool biology teacher that sells
weed after class only on middle-age so I
call it with the weed would you guys
like the weed my thanks to TBS for
really getting the word out on this show
they have gone above and beyond millions
millions of people saw this on
television just the other day check it
out on the east side of it you saw him
make that left turn I don't know what
Street that was that was 90 something
but now East now eased okay has stopped
okay let me get ahead that might have
been a garage
[Applause]
a TBS vice president of marketing stole
a car just for us yeah and I understand
he's out of surgery and recovery nights
you know another thing that's special
about tonight is that because of the
government shutdown the FCC is
completely out of commission yeah yeah
they are not overseeing the content of
American television right now so we're
not being monitored by the FCC tonight
that's right Andy those aren't watching
man